esto es todo lo que queda de esta casa
después de que un tornado arrasara la
ciudad de Selma en Alabama fuertes
vientos azotaron el jueves al sur de
Estados Unidos dejando territorio
desbastados
esto es mucho daño Toda mi casa está
patas arriba tenía una tienda justo ahí
ha desaparecido
varias personas han muerto entre ellas
un niño de 5 años en Georgia cuando un
árbol cayó sobre el coche en el que se
encontraba decenas de casas han quedado
destruidas en todos los estados del sur
al menos 23.000 residentes de Alabama
seguían sin electricidad el viernes por
la mañana mientras los empleos de las
compañías eléctricas trabajaban para
reparar los daños
la gobernadora del Estado key decretó el
estado de emergencia en los condados más
afectados el vecino estado de Georgia
hizo lo propio y también canceló las
clases en al menos seis condados el
viernes
sabemos de personas que quedaron varadas
y las casas literalmente se derrumbaron
y estaban debajo del sótano y ya sabes
estamos tratando de llegar a personas
así en este momento todavía tenemos
personas desaparecidas que tenemos que
averiguar dónde están y podrían estar
refugiándose en otro lugar
los tornados Siempre han sido habituales
en Estados Unidos Durante los meses
cálidos especialmente en el centro y el
sur del país pero los científicos
afirman que el fenómeno meteorológico
del jueves Es inusualmente dañino para
esta época del año